the tree takai llega and her children
are preparing their rice for market
their last harvest was successful and
they're selling their surplus we got
more rice than before before i was
getting eight bags from one acre and now
i can get 30 bags from an acre some
7,500 farmers formed a collective in the
columbia region any rice they don't
consume themselves or sell locally goes
to the company kilim Barrow plantation
limited or kpl the company trained
Richard hanga a local farmer to show
other farmers how they can improve their
crops using an egg salt and water he
explains how to choose and process seeds
the egg shows when the right level of
saturation of the brine is reached
that's when you drop in the seeds only
those sinking to the bottom should be
sown and that's not all play odawara
embed OBO i'm a big small holes with the
whole the whole should be about 25
centimeters apart acd Nina Tom when I
team-by-team and you put the fertilizer
in the hole first then the seed and then
you cover it with earth una campo de
algo pandya a la una y cambio la de una
vecchia besides helping the farmers grow
more rice kpl also promises to buy up
all of the surplus but the company pays
a lower price than markets in the area
agronomist Victor man Young has his
doubts about the scheme he says this
kind of agreement still leaves a great
deal of room for uncertainty is it a
model that can just be copied and pasted
I would say no is it a model that can be
scaled out a replicated with adaptation
yes Jose yes it is possible but we need
to learn from the mistakes made in
Colombia so that we don't repeat them
he says one problem is that the farmers
bear all the risk if there's a poor
harvest that's a good deal for the
company kpl argues that the farmers
benefit from knowing that they will find
a buyer for their surplus the kpl
doesn't pay the market price if the
foreign companies will be dealing with
that scheme they will impose the air
condition and the small-scale farmers
they will not benefit that much this is
where the government at least at the
beginning of the skim the governmental
Colin the government is powerful enough
to bring policy instrument at ritika
llega and her family still takes some of
their produce to the market instead of
selling it to kpl this way they earn
more per sack of rice and in both cases
they save the costs of a middleman